دعنا نتحدث عن تفاصيل عن اهميه هذه
الوديعه السعوديه للبنك المركزي اليمني
بمليار دولار كيف يمكن النظر اليها شكرا
لكم الله يحفظكم الحقيقه الوديعه هي جزء
من حزمه من الدعم التنموي والاقتصادي
للاشقاء في اليمن
هو مجموعه من الدعم تتكامل مع بعضها البعض
في خدمه الانسان اليمني وخدمه الاقتصاد
اليمني ودعم مجلس القياده الرئاسه اليمني
ليقوم بدوره هو والحكومه اليمنيه في خدمه
الانسان اليمني ومواجهه التحديات الصعبه
التي حقيقه يعانون منها بشكل كبير جدا
فالحزمه مكونه من مليار دولار من المملكه
ومليار دولار من الامارات المملكه اودعت
بالامس مليار دولار في البنك المركزي
اليمني وهذا سيساعد في دعم الاقتصاد
استقرار صعب سعر الصرف هذا سيساعد ايضا
التجار والرجال الاعمال في القدره على
شراء
استيراد وخاص المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه لو
نظرت العمر للوديعه السابقه 2018 اثنين
مليار دولار كان لها دور كبير في مساعده
استقرار سعر الصرف الريال اليمني وايضا
شراء المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه للشعب
اليمني عن طريق التجار رجال الاعمال
واستقرار السوق وبالتالي يتمكن من عمل
الدوره الاقتصاديه المتكامله الدعم ايضا
في مشتقات نفطيه هناك منحه مشتقات نفطيه
المرحله الثانيه المرحله الاولى كانت
باربع مئه وعشرين مليون دولار انتهت قبل
سته اشهر واستكملنا المرحله الثانيه
بتوفير مشتقات نفطيه لتشغيل المحطات
الكهرباء في عموم المناطق الخاضعه للسلطه
الحكومه اليمنيه هذه ليست مجرد تشغيل
محطات كهرباء هي اكبر من ذلك هي تساعد
الحكومه في عدم شراء
المشتقات النفطيم الخارج وبالتالي لن تسعى
الحصول على الدولار وبالتالي سيسهم في
استقرار سعر صرف الريال ثم ايضا سيسهم في
توفير الكهرباء لكل القطاعات المختلفه في
اليمن وبالتالي ساهمنا عن طريق هذه الحزمه
في المساعده الحكومه هناك ايضا
مبادره اخرى وهي صندوق مستدام لشراء
وتوفير مشتقات النفطيه للسوق اليمني هذا
يساعد الحكومه اليمنيه في عدم وجود
مضاربين على الدولار لانه التاجر عندما
يحضر المشتقات النفطيه الى اليمن يبحث عن
الدولار في السوق المحليه لشراء دفعه
الثانيه بالتالي اذا تمكنا من تمويل
الحكومه اليمنيه في صندوق مشتقات نفطيه
دوار بحيث تستطيع ان يشترى ويباع بسعر
ايضا ثابته ومستقر سيساعد ايضا في استقرار
الدولار بالاضافه مليار دولار التي
ابدعتها مملكه
وهناك ايضا مليار دولار لدى الامارات اودع
منها مبلغ في حساب البنك المركزي بالاضافه
الى المشتقات النفطيه من عندنا اضافه الى
مشتقات النفطيه وصندوق المشتقات ايضا
تكتمل الحزمه ب 400 مليون دولار مشاريع
تنمويه مختلفه منها محطات غاز لتبديل
الكهرباء في عدن عبر مشروع المشروع
البرنامج السعودي لتنميه عمر اليمن
في
للكهرباء تقريبا اربع مشاريع في عدن
ومحيطها كذلك المياه محطه تحليه مياه
وايضا تعزيز مصادر الطاقه المياه وهناك
مستشفى المكلف مستشفى كبير جدا
سيبدا تقريبا خلال شهر وشهرين البدء في
ترسيه المشروع هناك ايضا كليه الطب كليه
الصيدله وكليه التمريض في في طريقه العبد
بالاضافه الى طريق العبر مجموعه من
المشاريع الكبيره التي تساعد ان شاء الله
في خدمه الانسان اليمني دعم اقتصادي ودعم
مالي وديعه وكذلك اهتمام حتى بادق
التفاصيل سعه السفير في في الامور حتى
الصحيه وحتى امور التعليم وغيرها اسال هنا
عن هذا التزامن الدعم مع هذه الوديعه ايضا
انعكاسا على عمل مجلس القياده او الرئاسه
القياده ماده الرئاسه اليمني كيف تتوقعون
حيكون الاثر هو التوقع لكل اثرها كبير جدا
في مساعدتهم في تحمل اعباء الدوله تحمل
اعباء الكبيره جدا التي تنوء فيها الحكومه
اليمنيه ومشرقيات الرئاسي لكن انا اريد ان
اذكر بان المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
عقود تدعم الاشقاء في اليمن دعم الشقيق
للشقيق دعم الواجب تجاه الاخيه
وللتذكير في عندما انتقلت السلطه في عام
2012 دعمت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بمليار دولار وديع البنك المركزي وثلاثه
مليار و250 مليون دولار مشتقات نفطيه
وتقرابه الثلاثه مليار مشاريع مختلفه هو
2012 مليار 2018 مليارين
وهذه الدعوم هو الحقيقه المملكه
والتحالف يركزون على دعم الدوله
لو لا يمكن هناك دوله وحكومه وبنك مركزي
تابع لدوله سيكون من الصعب تقديم دعم
تنموي او دعم اقتصادي فبظل وجود هذه
القياده مجلس القياده الرئاسي ظل وجود
الحكومه اليمنيه وسعها للتغلب على
التحديات التي تواجهها حاليا سواء كان في
قدراتها او في مؤسساتها او في الكبشه
اللازمه لها الا ان هذا سيساعدها ان شاء
الله في تخطي كل الصعوبات ونرجو ايضا هذا
يساهم في دعم كل الاشقاء في اليمن ولو
عمرك بالنسبه للوديعه اللي في البنك
المركزي في عدن هي ليست خاصه بمنطقه معينه
هي خاصه بكل اليمن 70% تقريبا من
المواد الغذائيه التي تم شرائها في العام
2018 و19 وعشرين من وديعه السعوديه كانت
الى المناطق الخاطئه لسلطه الحوثيين
وبالتالي فهي تخدم الشعب اليمني والحكومه
اليمنيه هي حكومه لكل الشعب اليمني ذلك لا
تمييز ولا اقصاء لاي من الشعب اليمني هذه
الدعومات وخصوصا هذه الوديعه اسعد السفير
هل هي مشروطه بضمانات تتحدثون عن ضمانات
محاربه الفساد للحفاظ على استقرار
المؤسسات ايضا والتنميتها وحتى الوصول
للاهداف المنشوده لهذه الوديعه وحتى لمنحه
المشتقات النفطيه وحتى للمشاريع التنمويه
اللي عبر برنامج تنميه عمر اليمن الحقيقه
الحكومه اليمنيه ومسك يعملون بشكل واسع
على مواجهه هذه التحديات كما اشرتم اليها
متعلق مكافحه الفساد وقام وبعدم الاجراءات
سواء في القضاء في النيابه العامه في
تعزيز
جهاز مكافحه الفس ولكن هناك اجراءات
عملناها مع الحكومه اليمنيه بحيث يكون
هناك شيء اكبر من قضيه فقط مكافحه الفساد
هذا امر اساسي واصيل وهو احد الركائد
الاساسيه في تقديم هذه الوديعه بان لا
يكون هناك فساد وان تستخدم للشعب اليمني
وان تساهم في تعزيز الاحتياطات للبنك
المركزي اليمني لكن هناك مشروع اصلاحات
ناقشته الحكومه اليمنيه او قدمته الحكومه
الامنيه لصندوق العربي للنقد صندوق العربي
للنقد وصندوق لكل الدول العربيه ولديه
مشاريع كثيره مع اليمن من ضمنها بناء
قدرات البنك المركزي وبالتالي صندوق
العربي النقد اتفق مع الحكومه اليمنيه على
صندوق على مشروع اصلاحات مختلفه في
السياسه الماليه والسياسه النقديه وفي
العديد من المشاريع الاصلاح وبالتالي دخل
في
في برامج اصلاح ستساعد البنك المركزي في
النهوض
بوضع الاقتصاد اليمني وبالسياسه النقديه
وبالتالي جزء من هذا العمل هو مكافحه
الارهاب ومكافحه غسيل وايضا مكافحه الفساد
ورفع قد الدوله
تواصلكم مع الحكومه اليمنيه في في هذه
المشاريع الاصلاحيه المهمه
السفير هل بداوا فيها هل وصلوا فيها الى
مرحله متقدمه لمستموها انتم في الفتره
الماضيه لاحظنا زياده في قدره الحكومه على
زياده الايرادات وضبط البنك المركزي بشكل
افضل هناك جهود كبيره جدا لمواجهه
التحديات المختلفه في قدرات القدرات ضعيفه
جدا وبالتالي يحاولون زياده بناء القدرات
لدينا مشروع في البرنامج السعودي يتم
استعمار اليمن بالتنسيق مع الحكومه
اليمنيه لبناء قدرات المؤسسات الاساسيه
مساعدتها في النهوض وايضا هناك بناء قدرات
من البنك الدولي صندوق النقد الدولي
للاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا العديد من الدول
لمساعده الحكومه اليمنيه في بناء قدراتها
موجه التحديات الاقتصاديه والماليه لكن من
يتابع ومن يعمل مع البنك المركزي اليمني
هو صندوق العربي النقد بموجب الاتفاق
بموجب العلاقه بين الطرفين ونحن نقدم
التمويل وصندوق العربي النقد هو من يساهم
ويتابع في عمل الاصلاحات البرنامج اللي
تقومون برنامج تنميه اعمار اليمن ساعه
السفير هناك 17 مشروعا تنمويا تم الاعلان
عنها الفتره الاخيره كانت متزامنه مع منحه
المشتقات النفطيه اذا ما خانتني الذاكره
اللي كانت على مرحلتين ايضا المشاريع
التنمويه هناك اين وصلت هل هناك مشاريع
ايضا حتى قريبه سعه السفير نعم اول شيء
طال عمرك الحمد لله احنا من منتصف 2018
منذ انشاء البرنامج بتوجيه مولاي خادم
الحرمين الشريفين سيدي سمول العهد رسمي
الوزراء البرنامج ينفذ مشاريع كبيره جدا
ومختلفه جدا في عدم المحافظات عندنا 224
مشروع 52 مشروع تعليمي سلم 27 مدرسه
جامعه سبا انشاء لها قاعات وتم تاثها
جامعه عدن وكذلك هناك مشاريع اخرى في مجال
التعليم كذلك 38 مشروع في النقل فلدينا
طال عمرك مطار عدن مطار الغيظه وايضا
العديد من المطارات تطورنا فيها واوساهمنا
في تعزيز قدراتها طريق العبر 160 كيلو متر
وهو طريق يسمونه الاخوه اليمنيين طريق
الموت يتسبب في كثير من
الحوادث الاشقاء وهناك عمرك 31 مشروع في
الصحه ولعل المشروع مستشفى تشغيل عدن وهو
مستشفى العربيه السعوديه وعدنا تاهيله
خلال الفتره الماضيه وبدانا في التشغيل
270 سرير منها خمسين سرير للقلب وبدانا
ولله الحمد الاطباء يمنيين واجانب بعضهم
عمل المملكه العربيه السعوديه ويعمل الان
في عدن قاموا بعمليات
قلب ناجحه لاطفال ونساء ورجال وسيتتح ان
شاء الله قريبا فخامه الرئيس اليمني بحول
الله وايضا 33 مشروع في مجال المياه
مختلفه الانواع
و18 مشروع مجال الزراعه السمكيه 11 مشروع
للبناء ودعم المؤسسات الحكوميه وتقريبا 29
مشروع المجال الطاقه من ضمنها منحه
المشتقات النفطيه وكذلك 12 برنامج تنموي
هذه المشاريع الحقيقه ساهمت في جلب
المنظمات الدوليه استطعنا ان نقنع المجتمع
الدولي التحول من الاغاثه الى التنميه
وقدمنا نموذج جديد على مستوى العالم كيف
يمكن ان ندعم الحكومات في وقت الصراع
عنا مع الحكومه اليمنيه حاليا ونرجو ان
شاء الله انها تصل الى المناطق في حال ان
شاء الله الوصول للسلام بالتوفيق لكم ان
شاء الله شكرا لك على حضورك معي هنا في
استوديو نشره الرابعه السفير السعودي لدى
اليمن محمد الجابر شكرا لك